Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
First things first, Hank, you are a dad!
Katherine had a baby boy over the weekend;
his name is Orin, he is adorable and I
am SO SO HAPPY.
My excitement about this baby is at the level
of, like, Cheez Doodles guy.
Yaaaaa!!!!!!
This also means that Hank is really
and truly on paternity leave now, but fear
not; in the coming weeks we will have several
excellent Guest Hanks, beginning this Friday
with NerdyandQuirky Sabrina.
Second things second, next month will be the
10th annual Project for Awesome—wait is
that possibly correct?
Oh my God I'm old; I’m super old.
When did I become old?
It was this weekend, when my baby brother
had a baby.
I've gone from Cheez Doodles guy excited to
glimpsing the void in less than a minute;
but right the 10th Annual Project for Awesome
(no need to fear how old you’ve become)
will begin at noon eastern time on December
9th, and we need your help in a couple ways.
First, though, some background: The Project
for Awesome started in 2007, when Nerdfighteria
essentially tricked YouTube's algorithm into
featuring videos about charity.
Over the years, the Project for Awesome has
evolved a lot, but it's always been focused
on 1. decreasing the overall level of suck in the
world, and 2.
encouraging people to make great videos about
their favorite charities.
So here's how it's gonna work this year:
First, hopefully many of you will make Project
for Awesome videos: The idea here is that
on December 9th, you upload a video about
a charity you care about.
You explain why the work they do is so important
and how they do it well, and then you encourage
people to vote for your video at projectforawesome.com.
This is a great way to spread the word about
your favorite charities, and also the charities
that receive the most votes will get grants.
Last year, the top-voted charities received
$25,000 a piece.
Then there is the live show: So, for 48 hours
straight, beginning at noon eastern time on
December 9th, there will be a continuous
livestream here at the vlogbrothers channel
hosted by Hank and me and lots of special
guests.
In the livestream, we'll be highlighting our
favorite Project for Awesome videos, probably
covering our faces in peanut butter, and also
raising money for charity.
There will be an Indiegogo with lots of great
perks from all kinds of amazing YouTubers,
and all the proceeds will go to Nerdfighteria's
charity, The Foundation to Decrease Worldsuck,
which I know doesn't sound like a real charity,
but I promise it is one.
It is a federally sanctioned 501(c)3 organization,
and yes, your donations are tax deductible
if you live in the United States, and possibly
if you don’t, but I don't know your tax laws.
Right, okay, so the Foundation to Decrease
Worldsuck has no overhead because everyone
who works for it volunteers their time, which
means that 100% of donations, lest the cost
of producing and shipping physical perks,
goes to charity.
Over the last three years, we’ve raised
more than $3,000,000.
How do we choose the charities?
Well, during the first half of the project
for awesome, we raise money for pre-selected charities.
This year, they will be Save the Children
and Partners in Health.
These are both great organizations our community
has worked with for a long time.
And we've seen the impact that our donations
to Partners in Health and Save the Children
can have, from Bangladesh to Haiti to Ethiopia
to the United Sates to refugee camps in Jordan.
Pre-selecting charities also allows us to
gather matching donations, which means that
for the first half of the Project for Awesome,
every dollar you donate will be worth as at least $2.
Which reminds me: If you happen to be a person
who wants to make a very large donation to
this year’s Project for Awesome—say, anything
over $1,000—please email me at hankandjohn@gmail.com
with the subject line "Matching."
We will add your donations to the matching
fund and thank you profusely, and to reiterate:
Your donations are tax deductible.
Okay so then during the second half of the
Project for Awesome, we'll raise money for
charities chosen by you, the nerdfighter community,
via voting at projectforawesome.com.
Last year, winning charities ranged from water.org
to the American Association for Suicide Prevention.
It's up to you to decide what charities to make videos
about and which to support with your votes.
So here's what we could use from you right now
in comments:
One, perk ideas.
What perks would get you excited about donating
to this year's Project for Awesome?
Or, what perks have you loved in the past?
And number two, guest suggestions.
Are there people you would love to see on
the Project for Awesome livestream?
If so, let us know in comments.
Hank, congratulations congratulations congratulations!
I will not see you on Friday, but it’s okay—I
will see Sabrina, and you have a baby!